greetings a piece welcome to the deans
show if you haven't subscribed subscribe
right now we have an exciting show as we
always do have you ever put trust in
someone and they let you down that
ultimate trust now that should be given
to who we're going to be talking about
should be given to maybe you put all
your trust into money into insurance
into a spouse and at the ultimate end of
the day now you've gained you given this
trust to someone your heart your mind
your soul and they've let you down we're
going to be talking about the one when
you give that trust to him he will never
let you down and then you have that
contentment and peace that you're
probably missing this week's show don't
go anywhere we'll be right back this is
the
this is the thing you this is the days
of the danger this is the new I said I'm
alaikum peace be my new salon welcome to
locate dr. Massey how are you share and
think you'll handle it thank you thank
you for being with us on the Dean show
you more than welcome thank you now I
opened up the show and I talked about
you know insurance I talked about a
spouse and obviously you know we have
some trust in the vehicle that we're
driving and our spouse that maybe you
know they won't do certain things but we
are talking about that ultimate trust
and Reliance that now when a lot of
times when you have on an insurance
company for instance and you you you now
it lets you down because they ain't
cover you know the hurricane that just
came through and now you're lost you
become hopeless so we want to talk about
you know having that ultimate trust save
for who bismillah al rahman al rahim
allah praise be to Allah subhana Allah
and peace be upon his servant and last
messenger our beloved prophet muhammad
sallallahu ala all this trust should go
toward Allah Subhan o attire he is the
one and the only one can lift you up
from the hopelessness we live in from
the disaster situation we live in
especially nowadays when muslims oma
become like strangers and all the
circumstances around us is terrible
problems disaster we move from problem
to another one from disaster situation
to a worst one all of us should flee to
allah subhan allah tala and trust him
the most otherwise we are losers now
what does that mean you know like
someone things okay so I just trust in
allah and what I just you know
everything's supposed to be okay when we
say trust in a lot for the for that is
pretty what it would trust in God what
that mean what does entail that's a good
question a trusting a lot doesn't mean
you sit down and just wait for his
victory to grant you victory while you
are sitting let's go back together to
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
and they start looking how he trusted
allah subhan allah tala what he did in
addition to this a trust this is the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him once
while he was walking the street he saw
ID you'd know how to multi he told him
yeah Adi Adi Alamo melody em now Camille
Islam I know what prevents you from
Islam in a kotaku luffy nasik you say to
yourself in a Muslim in alpha alpha Cara
a mockery Muslims are poor weak not
respected then now listen to what he
told him yachad e hadi a day will come
for this Ummah when the woman traveling
from ha drama to matka have no fear but
allah subhana tile kiss raza treasurers
will be captured by the Muslims uma
adhesive no hat on Tiger chucked kiss
Robin Hormuz the prophets are llamas
haven't confirmed the three times kiss
Robin Hormoz kiss hablar mas que
hablamos let's now take a look together
what the prophets allah salam said when
and what he said he said that in the
beginning of the Dawa when there is no
government or authority to help him
salala salem most if not all of his
followers were slaves have no power no
authority people give up on islam
because they did not see any supporters
at that moment he talked and he plant
salama cell and the hope in Muslims in
week Muslims that time hearts by saying
idea will come win kiss was treasurer
will be captured by the Muslims oma so
he gives him a hint why he gives such a
big hope a bigger province while he
lived in very weak situation because he
trusted a loss of her metallic promises
so in addition to we trust allah subhana
allah he did not stop moving he kept
going forward working for this Dean but
never ever lose a trust in Allah subhana
Allah never be hopeless of a las mercy
of a las victory of Allah supremacist
since Allah subhana Allah promised him
with the victory sooner or later that's
it to him it's done deal and he started
going toward this line he never stops a
llama Helios on at that week situation
the same thing a high delegation from
courage came to him offering him many
thing and they told them or Prophet
Muhammad we are willing to worship your
God one day you worship or just next one
if it's a la la solemn did not respond
then they offer them more o prophet
mohammed we are willing to worship your
God one full week you worship or just
one day or one day a week for our God
full week for yours never responds then
he said so they offered him more or
Prophet Muhammad we are willing to
worship your God one full month and you
worship all just one day a month never
responds then he they offer them sorry
they offered him o prophet mohammed we
are willing to worship your God one full
year and you worship or just one day a
year one day a year his response a lala
haria seldom is Allah subhana Allah give
him the response hulia you Hal Katherine
la algo tu mata bodu Bala and drama i
doona mohabbat wala and i we do mavattam
para tomar una my abode locanda no como
el eid o Muhammad say to those
disbeliever
I worship not what you worship nor you
worship what I worship he confirmed this
statement twice then he said you have
your own way and I have mine shake we're
going to take a break and we'll come
back to cover this very important topics
or more here on the Dean show please
subscribe to the dvo follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below please also help support
the D show by making a donation in the
link below back here on the Dean show
with dr. omar Shaheen now the person
shake says you know what I trust in the
almighty dollar what do you tell them
you are trusting the wrong the wrong one
because who is giving you the daughter
who is giving you the risk who is giving
you the money who is it provide with all
of these things a lot of hinata who is
lift up yours you spiritual wise who who
who does everything for you a loss of an
attack doesn't it say even on the dollar
and God We Trust isn't it interesting as
the topic we're talking about have you
seen it says and gas we trust that's
what I respect this money this is one of
Allah's favours and we should take care
of it and we should work for it and the
trusting allah means i should believe
that he is the one and the only one can
give or care take back that's number one
number two we should work to get this
dollars this money in a very lawful
hallelu so this is kind of start and
it's connection with the trust Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him when he
immigrated from Mecca to Medina horizon
after him everyone one hundred camels
for whoever bring Muhammad did or life
and guess what soraka blue Malik reach
him and few foots between feets between
him and the Prophet Muhammad Saleh but
surah i noticed that his horse is
drowning in the sand so that moment
prophet muhammad peace be upon him look
at him look listen to this what kind of
strength is strong with trust over
awesome honiton at this moment
weaknesses very weak situation he is in
the middle of the desert would only hit
one of his friend abubakar sadiq
hadiyyah-lah 10 everybody after him but
what he said yes oaxaca energy i wanna
keswani kissa go back and I promise you
with a bracelet of kiss from your Allah
what kind of promises this you just lift
your beloved city Mecca you have no
supporters there they give you a hard
time even your close relatives and now
you promised with the bracelet of casa
yes he did why because he trusting Allah
subhana vittal the most and he trusts
that Allah will never put him down he
trusts allow the promises do we have the
same interest or we don't that's a big
question we should ask ourself every
night before we go to sleep what kind of
dress I have but we have to notice that
in addition to this a trust what he did
Sal Allah Allah he did not stay in
Medina and Mecca I'm sorry and he said
oh I trust allah he will grant me Victor
know he did action so action and the
Trust goes together we should trust
allah subhana allah the most but before
and after we should do some actions but
keep silent standing sitting and in our
homes doing nothing that's not Islam
Islam need you to trust and do some
action that's what the prophets allah la
salle did he promised with the bracelet
of kisser and he while he was going to
medina in order to save his deen his
faith and establish a Muslim country a
Muslim government get around him the
supporters then in overall Mars rhodiola
one who days he conquered anodyne and
they brought all wolf and booted before
omar and they told
mother along when he saw that he started
crying and he said I swear by Allah who
brought this world is an honest man the
pas de Familia man stood up and he is
the one he was the one who brought this
world and he told him yay Amira you mean
Oh Amira mooney Dada 55 phat rahi took
10 hotel Econo try 80 you are honest
people an honest person your people
become unless people like you otherwise
they will be otherwise then he asked for
the bracelet of Kucera and called Soraka
and give it to him and he told him this
is the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him promise so this is the trust we need
in our life imagine that overall most
days after the Allah subhana Allah
fulfill the prophets our solemn promise
after his death and he never felt that
there is something wrong if Allah
promised them something it's over it's
done deal do we do we believe it this
way or we don't that's a question we
need to take actions in addition to the
trust we should fill our hearts with so
this is a scenario that you painted this
was actually a bounty hunter that was
coming to get this actually a prophecy
that was fulfilled we have many
established facts not fiction in the
Quran and science and other prophecies
which you just mentioned was actual
prophecy that the prophet saw some had
told this bounty hunter that he would go
ahead and get these bracelets from
kisser and then this actually transpired
is amazing tell us shake that now for
somebody to have trust and their creator
let's say many people become despondent
they fall into despair because now it's
one calamity after next and they start
panicking and they think and it becomes
worse because they think now that the
Creator Allah is angry with me so now
they become even more sad and fallen to
despair absolutely we never as a as a
muslim's you never we never he never she
never should be hopeless of Allah's
mercy no matter what we have done no
matter what how many kinds of sins we
have done never be hopeless of
hinata Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him in a hospital he went to take a nap
rest at that moment one of the
disbelievers get to him Salaam Salaam
and put the salt over his neck like this
and he started he wake him up call me
Mohammed wake of Mohammed many am NOT ok
mineola and who will protect you now
Mohammed prophet sallallahu
alehiwassallaam with fully trust open
his eyes and look at him and answer the
questions easy as simple as Allah who i
am now anemic allow am not naming allah
protect me from you the disbeliever the
minute the second he heard the word
allah he starts shaking and the sort
fall down so the prophet muhammad peace
be on pick it up and put it over the
mushrik nick and he told him who will
protect you now so the disbeliever start
digging the Prophet SAW mahlasela and
the prophets allah salam set him free as
usual this kind of trust we need even in
the very in the worst circumstances
around us the only trust or the only one
we should trust allah subhana allah
because he is the only one capable to
save us from all what we face in our
life there is an amazing example in
scenario we're going to go to break but
not only do we see that trust in the
Creator but also the mercy of the last
and final messenger he wasn't traveling
off his head yes he let him go yes even
though he threatened his life up so this
is the prophets allah la solana maisie
that's the last and final messenger sent
a man kind of problem ahamed peace be a
partner who is a brother to Jesus Moses
Abraham they all came with the same
message worship the Creator not the
creation we'll be right back with more
here on the Dean show please subscribe
to the dvo follow us on our official
facebook and twitter pages in the links
below please also help support the d
show by making a donation in the link
below
back here on the Dean show with dr. omar
Shaheen thank you again for being with
us now let's go back to some people say
yeah I trust in Allah but the person
let's say is not establishing the
commands in their life from the
injunctions in their life that the
Creator is home to do prior five times a
day you know Good Conduct good character
developed in themselves to be a better
human being each and every day so they
might be deceiving in business relations
you know doing things that they
shouldn't be doing gambling smoking
alcohol and the prince is love I trust
in God does that have to be now current
seidel obedience to god it doesn't work
a trust without action it's nothing
trust and you need to work for this a
trust to empower this a trust and
transfer it to action if this it rust
you did not transfer it to action it
looks like you have done nothing let's
go to other prophets like braheem Elise
and I'm you just mention braheem peace
be upon him after all what he have done
for the sake of Allah calling his people
calling his father and do this do that
try to convince them that they should
worship Allah subhana Allah they decide
to burn him alive after all of this
action and they put him in the cult
vault and they are about to throw him
into the fire Abraham Abraham peace be
upon him at that moment look now to the
trust it's had it took place after the
trust before and after after the action
I'm sorry the angel came to him asking
him or braheem alaka haja do you need
anything from me oh my god listen to
this answer he said am a mincha fella
ameman who fail moo-hoo be Holly uni and
so Ali has to be a la Anunnaki from you
and angel he's talking to an angel I
don't need anything but from Allah
Subhan Allah Tala he knows my situation
he is going to take care of me has to be
a la una Milwaukee
then Allah Subhan Allah Ta'ala responds
to this doha response to this is trust
by commanding the fire to be peace and
cool and braheem and this is what
happened no mediator no third party
between you and Allah Subhan Allah Tala
you have to trust allah subhana allah
the most ibrahim alayhis salaam when he
asked Allah subhana Allah he did not ask
the angel even we know that the angel
help our have authority by allah so
allah tala but he direct this to Allah
subhana Allah Allah saved him by
commanding the fire we should trust even
Allah subhana Allah world's one of the
email Marik's students his name is sat
noon he used to recite al-fatiha her
over any sick person just a fatty yeah
and Allah Subhan Allah grant him a
coolness right away once a sick very
sick person came to him travelling
actually traveled to him but they told
them I'm sorry immense at home passed
away one of his students he felt sorry
for this sick person so he told him I
know what my Imam my sheer used to
recite he recycled fair to her once
twice tries first day second day nothing
changed getting worst so he said the
beautiful statements has a lot to do
with the trust he said this is al fatiha
were lacking a naoki knows I noon had
the hill fatty howl a canonical year
Tino's on this is alpha t about what is
de Akino say noon we all recite
al-fatiha 17 times minimum a day do we
trust what we are saying do we practice
what we are reciting yak an avid what
year concern we worship no one but you
we seek no help but yours do we believe
it do we practice this in our life or we
don't that's a big question need an
answer yes one of the good people was
going home have one loaf of bread one
Aoife if may
a poor person asking for charity asking
for charity so this person because he
trusted Allah subhana Allah he said if I
give him one Allah will give me 10 as
promised in the Quran that's the trust
of a las promises he give it to him he
went home his wife asked him where is
the food listen to his answer he told
her it is coming why because he trusts a
loss of hannah Tala the most i give 10
i'll take tin how I don't know it's a
large business when I don't know it's a
las business but he have this a trust
and he he believed that he won't be more
generous than Allah saw hinata if I
human beings felt sorry for a human
beings Allah Subhan Allah won't let me
go hungry and sleep with my family
hungry so few minutes later somebody
knocking his door he opened the door
this person carrying something he told
in this as a gift from my master so he
said jazakallah khairan thank you very
much but wait a minute he's open it he
found lous of bread and he start
counting 1 2 3 5 7 8 9 he said
jazakallah khairan but what is the 10th
said my god how do you know it were 10
he said because I give one I should get
10 just that I was a lot what Allah
subhana Allah promised me and others he
told them one by you are right I ate it
in my way to you so this is the trust
this kind of trust we need we need to
trust allah subhan allah ta'ala when our
child god forbid god said or one of us
the first thing you should come to your
mind not medical insurance not i am
friend of dr. I know diagnose I can
diagnose this disease I have the
medicine you should trust allah the most
that he is the
and the only one who grant you curious
what Allah said were either murdered 24
who is fine when I got sick allograft
Mickey earnest not Mayo Clinic not your
medical insurance not the medicine in
the pharmacy not all doctors you know
unless the one and the only one candy
Grand Duke illness when you believe it
this way when this comes first to your
mind Allah will get you to the right
doctor and he will guide the doctor to
the right medicine and he will put in
this medicine the coolness you are
asking for otherwise we are losers buta
for advice thank you again for being
will first medically and reward you
chucklehead a psychological demography
Salaam alaikum so there you have it the
answer to all of your problems is when
you take the necessary action that you
need to do the capabilities that God has
given you you take them and you act upon
whatever you need to do you go out there
you do your best to get that job you do
your best to find the cure for that
ailment but at the end of the day you
put all your reliance and trust on the
Creator the one who created you and
that's how you'll be successful so thank
you for tuning in to the D show again
subscribe if you haven't already follow
us on the facebook twitter and be back
with us again next week for another
exciting show until then peace be with
you